- On this episode, I bring the bucket.
Leo and DeMayo.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 136
of the #AskGaryVee show.
I'm fired up.
It is, like I said, mug
mug, it is muggy as hell
in New York City.
I'm sweating right now,
disgusted by the weather,
but very excited because today
is an extremely special day.
That special day is the
fact that it is my father
Sasha Vaynerchuk's birthday.
Happy birthday dad, I
love you very very much.
All of you that watch the show
know how much of a factor my parents are
in my life and
the time I spent with my dad working
every weekend, every holiday, vacation,
every summer, and then the first decade
of my professional career are moments
I think about all the time
are constantly running
in my brain in parallel
as I navigate the world,
and I love you very much, dad.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday Plya,
Plya my former assistant.
Oh, we have that Instagram photo
of me and all the assistants.
Let's put that up.
Let's not forget that.
Plya, happy birthday
and so we've got that, and then
big shout out to Facebook Live,
because we're doing that right now.
DeMayo, holding it down.
Current assistant status,
and that's about it I think.
There's a football game tonight.
The level of hate that I have
for both of these franchises
I mean the disdain I have for
Pittsburgh and New England
is so over the top I'm
not even gonna go into it,
but there is one picture from
the way I was reacting to
the Steeler fans last year in New York.
DRock, oh Staphon, by the way,
let's actually start talking about this.
Staphon has taken over core
editing, editing
control and so,
all the love you're giving to DRock
now needs to shift to Staphon.
At the same token, all the razing
you gave DRock for getting
the fire balls last time,
that was Staphon's major miss.
Rookie mistake, we'll let it go this time.
DeMayo you might be editing this show
if Staphon makes another mistake.
Alright.
Let's bucket, bucket,
let's get into
the show.
You've been asking for it.
Stunwin will be very happy that we've
actually used the Reddit community
to get feedback, and the
bucket which I don't even,
DRock you're the only one
that has a prayer here.
Do you know what episode
the bucket was on?
Oh Staphon,
the bucket made an appearance once.
People liked it.
We're bringing it back.
Random questions from the bucket.
Andy K is here
I feel like you're Leonardo DiCaprio in
growing pains, like a random
new person out of no where.
That was a tremendous compliment.
Alright Andy, here we go.
Let's read them up.
- [Andy] Hi Gary Vee,
why would you spend money
on a Facebook dark post
on me when I follow you
and I have notifications
on, isn't it a waste of money?
- This is tremendous,
because you read this.
This is like so serendipitous.
If you guys don't know, Andy does a ton
of the paid performance around my brand
and Wine Library, and so Andy
I think you actually
can answer this question
better than I can.
What we're targeting is we're
targeting my fans on certain content,
retargeting them, because
organically you're not
reaching everybody when
you post something,
and there's certain things
I want everybody to see.
Andy, am I right or wrong
or do we even know yet
what the new notification,
with the way notifications are on
there's no way to exclude people that have
put us on First Look or anything yet.
- Yet.
- Yet and that's it.
The answer to the
question is quite simple.
The reason I'm targeting you is because
there are certain pieces
of content that I wanna
make sure as many people
as possible will see
above and beyond my normal organic reach
which is pretty high.
We tend to get 60 or
100,000 of the 320,000
that we have, which is extremely high,
but sometimes I want all 320,000 of you
on Facebook to see something.
I'm willing to waste those pennies.
Not to mention, is it a waste sometimes?
Think about, you know what, DRock,
get back here. Get Andy out of the way.
Let's get focused for a second here.
Here's a little side question
for statement of the day,
let's go into the statement
of the day number one here.
In the comment section
on YouTube and Facebook
please step up lurkers.
You're pissing me off.
Summer's over.
Vacation is over lurkers.
Get your asses in the comments.
This show is ****ing free.
I need comments from you.
It is my oxygen.
As you can tell I'm not joking around.
Leave in the comments if you've watched
a piece of content more than once.
The answer is, let me
save you a lot of time,
the answer is most of you have watched
tons of my content more than once,
and so even if it's wasted, a lot of times
somebody will watch a second time,
a third time.
One of the great ego boosts I get are
the emails I get that says things like
wow I just watched this
talk for the seventh time,
and I picked up on new things,
because as your career
evolves, same with mine,
as our careers evolve, other things that
were said now mean more than
they did six months ago.
That's why I do it.
Andy.
- Gary Vee, jab, jab, jab, right hook!
What's your business model behind the
#AskGaryVee show?
- The business model
behind the #AskGaryVee
show is pretty simple.
It is completely a
broad awareness game.
I want more exposure.
Exposure is leverage, especially
when you've got chops.
The more people that know that
I'm not just charisma, hyperbole,
bullshit hype,
and that I have depth is something
that is important for my brand.
Statement of the day,
in the comments leave
if you originally thought
that I was just another
bullshit marketer, and have I won you over
with you doing the homework about me
actually building real
business multiple times,
and have listened to things
that I've talked about
here that you won't expect
from a bullshit marketer.
Anything that puts me in a position
to show my depth in a world where I know
that my personality
creates a scenario where
people may not think
that I have that depth
is an important process for me.
Once I have the infrastructure
to be able to do it,
I did it and so the business
model is quite simple.
It's about more leverage around me
which leads to in the short term
things like getting paid
for public speaking,
selling more books, getting asked to do TV
and other things, and
getting on 40 under 40 list
which creates more
exposure and it's a rapid
wheel.
It leads to better employees coming
into VaynerMedia.
It leads to more people
buying on Wine Deals,
the greatest place on
Instagram to buy wine.
It leads to a lot of other things.
It leads to depth with current employees,
'cause they get to see
so much more about me.
As a matter of fact, here's
a statement of the day.
VaynerMedia lurkers, because
I know there's a lot of you.
Some of you have been
writing some awesome feedback
notes that are completely
taken from the #AskGaryVee Show.
VaynerMedia employee
lurkers, get in the comments
on this episode and say hey.
It's given me the ability
to scale my thoughts
and strategies to my own employees.
There is, my mom gets to see me everyday.
She watched yesterday's episode twice,
because A.J. was in it.
Two for one, for mom,
mom I love you.
There's enormous, enormous
amounts of ROI business
models in the concept
of putting out great content.
Putting out great content,
if I may say so myself,
is always the right idea.
DeMayo they're gonna like that one.
I think you're gonna
get some good comments
there from Facebook Live.
- Some guy is saying he was watching
driving 77 miles per hour.
- [Gary] Alright, dude.
Do not do that.
Do not drive and watch the show.
It's dangerous.
- Gary Vee, tips to reach only
local residents on social.
We have a recycling program
that's specific to our county.
- You weren't on Andy there.
Oh but you caught him?
Good, edit that,
because if you saw Andy's reaction
as the paid performance guy
it's a ludicrous question.
It means that
as a matter of fact, what I just said,
ludicrous question, can
you guys impose Ludacris
in between, like next to me.
- [Ludacris] Move get out the way
- I
oh baby,
it's a ludicrous question if
you've been watching the show.
Who asked that question?
- [Andy] Liz.
- Liz, if you've been
watching the show for the last
whatsoever, 130 episodes,
then I think you're
just mailing in your question, but
I'm glad you got on the show, because
it's fun to be on the show,
but Liz, it's so simple.
Facebook targeting.
That's it.
You can literally put
your business address
and run a radius around it,
or everybody in the 07081 zip code
or the 08802 Asbury, Jersey in the house.
Zip code, and everybody will see it
in that zip code, in that feed.
It's a piece of cake.
You can do localized
ads with Instagram now.
You can do localized ads with Twitter.
It's the only place
you can do this kind of stuff outside
of direct mail, which
is very, very expensive
for the ROI of the attention, because
everybody throws their direct mail
in the trash.
Like this question.
Next.
Next, I hope we don't
ask the same question.
- #AskGaryVee
- Oh you need this?
Not really, you don't need the paper.
You don't need it.
- What are the differences
in the way you deal with
small vs big accounts/clients?
- There's a ton of differences.
When you're dealing with
small or big businesses
senior or junior employees,
big or small in all shapes and sizes
in business
really dictate very different strategies.
Small accounts a lot of times don't
have the same budgets.
Small accounts often have
chips on their shoulder
and lack confidence.
I think one of the great things we do
for small accounts is
actually bring a little
bravado to them.
I'm more comfortable actually
coming from small to going big, because
that's what I do.
You need to be scrappier.
You need to build self esteem more.
I think big needs the
reverse a lot of times.
We need to make sure they
don't waste their money,
because the sorrows of riches,
or what is it, help me.
What is it called?
Anyway, right,
thanks for being there for me Andy.
The spoils of riches or
whatever it's called.
They have so much money sometimes they
just mail in and waste a ton of it.
I think a lot of time our biggest
brands need a huge level of humility.
It's really the yin
and yang to each other.
I think the small
accounts need that bravado
and self esteem and like
we can do this, screw the big guy.
If we're smarter we can beat them.
They're wasting money on TV and other
dumb shit.
Big accounts stop wasting money on
dumb shit, you're not as big and as cool
as you think you are.
Somebody small can come and catch you.
Those tend to be the two
different religious pillars
and they're very important
and having those strategies
at the top really really do matter.
Oh, right.
It's on me today.
Great job, India.
Gary Vee, Do you think
people's attention is
reaching a max?
I.E., it's now a fight
between social platforms
to grab the pieces.
- I think I understand the question.
We only have so many
hours in a day, right?
I think the basis of the
question is very simply
how many hours of attention are really
up for play?
You've got television.
You've got sleeping.
You've got eating.
You've got working.
You've got your phone
that has tons of content.
You have video games.
You have
going to the bar.
You have fantasy football.
You have all these things
pulling at your attention.
You have your kids.
You have your book club.
There's only so many hours.
The leisure hours or the consumption hours
have absolutely stayed the same while
the amount of content
vying for that attention
has exploded.
Our grandparents had three goddamn TV
channels and two newspapers and two
radio stations vying for our attention.
That's how you got big.
That's how Walter Chronkite
was the most famous person in America.
Now we have massive fragmentation,
and so yeah I think the attention has not.
The attention has stayed stable while
the things pulling at that attention
have grown exponentially
especially over the last 15 years,
and the internet has
I mean if you think cable television
or video games of the Nintendo era,
or all, or Direct TV
then later compares at
all to what the internet
is doing.
It's 1,000 to one.
The web and the phone,
I mean the phone has become.
It's unbelievable to me how
absolutely essential that phone is.
Xander dropped my phone on Sunday
and me and Matt were scrambling on Monday.
Me and Matt were scrambling,
because Tuesday I was going to LA,
and I didn't have my phone
for 15 hours and I was
freaking the hell out.
It was unbelievable.
It was kind of chill actually,
but it only worked for me because it was
Monday, Labor Day into Tuesday
and I was home with the family.
If I was not not have my phone now.
The only time we ever
fix my phone otherwise is
when I'm in the office.
I'm here, okay,
but literally I was walking
around with my laptop.
Thank God I had my update
on my iOS, so my text messages were coming
in as chat, but otherwise I would
have been like whatever.
To answer your question, yeah
I think it's a war.
It will be a continuous war
and the size, the big
things in our society
are gonna be smaller and smaller,
because everybody is gonna
go into their niches.
We're gonna micro celebrity,
micro trends, that long tail is gonna
be really, really, really, really long.
Real long, super long.
Great episode.
Tomorrow is one of the
most special episodes
in the history of the #AskGaryVee show.
I will actually say on record right now
it will absolutely be my favorite
all time #AskGaryVee episode, 100.
Throw up the 100 emojis
and don't forget, Staphon.
You keep asking questions.
'Cause the statement of the day,
we've done that.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)